bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi è
domenica e quindi siamo sempre visto
ragazzi sta frase ormai la dico una
volta ogni tre settimane perché c'è
sempre qualcosa che si mette di mezzo
quando devo fare se non so perché è
comunque salva ma iniziamo così senza
capire neanche il coso cliccato va beh
chi se ne fotte
[Musica]
va bè ragazzi visto che è più vissuta
mente non ho idea di che cazzo abbia ma
non si riesce a far partire avete detto
che esiste che bello 3 cat mario 3d è
bellissimo il modello 3d è una delle
cose più belle
ok
stavo dicendo il modello 3d è uno dei
più belli che io abbia mai visto
oddio mazurka sud dove sei dove sei una
donna mi ha stirato di brutto ragazzi
non ho capito il senso di loro c'è 11 si
può muovere in aria anche dopo che ha
saltato c'è una cosa improponibile
comunque ragazzi il modello 3d gli store
che marian la cosa più bella che io
abbia mai visto in un video c'è non so
che cazzo di senso può avere un gioco
così
ok fermi fermi perché cazzo mi è caduta
una balena coi baffi in testa al bello
nel buio giri che offriamo noi con
tantissima soltanto devo soltanto
saltare su ok ok
oddio mamma mia mamma mia che provi a
emerso anche giocare senza nome senza
una mano ho chiesto ma sono salvo per
miracolo che la smetta di fare il
[ __ ] perché so che muoio tanto come
faccio e alto 14 chilometri come cazzo
lo supero sto vuoto e altro nel mio caro
amico giovanni non si può fare
kat
ai ragazzi non avevo tenuto conto del
salto strabico di cat mario lombardo a
me non importa andiamo avanti comunque
faccia passato punto per quanto mi
ricordi non mi hanno dato le ali cazzo
come fa pdl on.le madonna abbiamo sei le
cose bellissimo aspettate un attimo fuga
dove l'air africa si si eh vabbè ma caso
mosca [ __ ] a quanto ho capito come
rifare tipo così si ok ok potente
effetto
no ce la posso fare un giudice di
saltare qui sopra si ok allora adesso ci
dovrei essere che cazzo succede regalo
che cazzo oddio slalom e slalom
incredibile riaprendo non mi hanno
neanche toccato si stronzi ma
schiacciate raga io non ho capito per
adesso salvo questo pro key adesso vado
la struttura ora sta merda dovrebbe
essere un checkpoint
pochi anche i duplicati che cazzo ne so
io ragazzi adesso ci abbiamo checkpoint
devo fare slalom
perché mi sto scoprendo un gatto cos'è
un orgia e perché ne arrivano altri cosa
ha fatto uno a testa
allora questo cosa dovrebbe essere un
checkpoint intanto avete sbagliato a
scrivere premi visto
[Musica]
ok ok ok ok sono morto nella ragazzi dal
modello 3d visto che mario mi fa
veramente ribrezzo se poi arrivano i
tifosi e iniziano a stuprarmi la cosa
non migliora sappiatelo in questo l'ho
passato il tutto passato il film si
fugate tutti i sensi
apriti scordava [ __ ] allora questa
è la casa è una casa minuscola che mi
sembra quella del mulino bianco ci manca
solo che trovo banderas con rosita che
mi deve allora aprista apposta ma è
troppo è troppo lontano papa ragazzi
come banderas non mi aprirà mai la porta
del mulino bianco diventare lo stage 2
anche se sinceramente un po paura di
vedere che cazzo anche ha fatto fuori
così non si fa neanche partito sono già
morte raga io ma mai così marcato mamma
mia che fai la madonna o l mamma mia
mamma mi chiama ci sto capendo un cazzo
perché va troppo veloce
siamo ok ok
[Musica]
sì io io mamma mia che prova adesso vado
direttamente lì vado direttamente non
vado avanti perché faccio una figura di
merda ok ok dio santo che lei ha detto
no perché è piazzato ma per formare ma
stiamo scherzando veramente mi ha
lasciato il gioco alla fine va veramente
me che lasciato il gioco dove tornava a
[ __ ] tulic su quella gatta che et ha
creato tua sorella e tutti i muri nella
santi allora io io io non so che cazzo i
ragazzi basta io non voglio giocare più
a un cat mario in vita mia impossibile
che io io non ho
[Musica]
io calmi calmi ragazzi carmine madonna
santissima che prova che pro allora io
non tocco più quel cazzo di cosa perché
mi cresce al gioco cos'è sta roba
ok sono diventati no relax ragazzi non
ho capito perché sono diventato enorme
non vedo un cazzo se devo car devo
camminare di lato perché non vedo un
cazzo di dove sto andando ad allenarti
moro saltare giusti colli ma sono enorme
che cazzo salto questo che cos'è sono
morto su delle spine che cazz è successo
oggi e ragga meglio non prenderlo quel
non so che cazzo e qualcosa allucinogeno
ma meglio lasciar perdere
ok ok ma donna morì c'era una spina su
c'era una spina lì sopra c'è una spina
moon santissima allora immaginate che io
ho già sclerato abbastanza no e allora
perché mi fate giocare a sta merda
perché perché perché c'è una foca che
dorme chissenefrega
vai così si ok non so come sto riuscendo
a queste cose non ci posso credere a
scala per il paradiso il credito 350
allora ma lei visto semaforo ragazzi non
vedere senso di creare una cosa così
insulsa dopo già un videogioco che di di
sua era insulso che cazzo che cos'è sta
roba dove cazzo siamo in attesa di alvi
che cazzo sono spuntate due tette in
basso è normale ti chiedi chi sei tu
maledetti stupratori ragazzi mi hanno
travolto due carrarmati ma questo punto
scusi ma devo vedere l'ultima perché se
questi non avevano senso io non so cosa
aspettarmi adesso vi giuro
perché che mario sta dormendo io io sono
qui a sclerare come un [ __ ] tu dormi
e che cazzo dormi sveglia perfetto
allora non piaccia a dare più a dormire
mentre e giocando in casa
cos'è la casa dichiara mario questa
madonna amico mio per l'arredamento ti
dico io che ci hai un gusto del cazzo
c'è proprio sentitamente
te lo dico in amicizia che poi tra
l'altro non so perché tutto enorme in
confronto a me ma non importa andiamo
avanti di qua ma ma se tipo io esco
dalla porta principale mi si apre al sì
si apre la porta principale cos'è sta
roba cos'è sta roba perché c'è un treno
che arriva perché si muove così
ragazzi non è normale che ci siano dei
binari è un treno che sta passando su
dei binari che si muove cosa sta
succedendo allora prendo il treno al
volo
vai così si un cazzo mi sta per mettere
sotto ma non importa
va beh se è arrivato in ritardo
probabilmente sedi tra in italia sono
così convinto cos'hai prendo il treno è
iniziata la lezione che cazzo fate
chiuso altre ragazze ok ho preso tre
bellissimo guanda allora mi attacco al
treno diretto a [ __ ] credo sia quella
destinazione più che questa non posso
crederci otterrà da qualche parte sono
che cazzo non ha fatto poi cos'è ragazzi
sta diventare è diventato tutto bianco
non si sa perché sono in paradiso dove
siamo ok sono al cospetto del dio gatto
ragazzi non è normale sta cosa mi
inchino a lei purtroppo non le ginocchia
ma lo farei volentieri le immagini che
io lo abbia fatto tanto rispetto sua
eminenza non capisco se quella è la sua
quota 66 infilato una boccia nel culo ma
non importa io se non le dispiace vado
avanti di qua perfetto grazie quella è
la fine di che mario 3d dove arrivare là
sopra tu sai mi stai prendendo per il
culo vero ragazzi allora io direi che
sta cosa infattibile posso concludere
qui non hai da lei perché l'abbiano
fatta da me era già faceva schifo prima
all'importante che l'abbiano fatto in 3d
così ho capito e può fare ancora più
schifo
ragazzi io direi che posso concludere
senza e pensate che questo modello di
che mario sia orribile lasciato un
commento mi piace è stato riscritto
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo il prossimo
video e sperando che è primis funzioni
ragazzi